so you've got a pretty sweet-looking
control but what about users who can't
see the shiny hotness accessibility is a
key consideration when building apps and
particularly when you're creating new
views you can start by adding a Content
description as you would for every other
view in your layout to ensure that they
are all accessible but what about views
like our wind speed and direction gauge
where the content isn't static knowing
you're looking at a wind gauge isn't
very useful if you don't know what the
speed and direction it's displaying are
well there are a couple of options here
for generic views which don't control
their own values the simplest
alternative is to set the content
description within your app at runtime
and even more robust solution is to send
an accessibility event from within your
view whenever the visual content has
been modified then override the dispatch
populate accessibility event adding the
Kara controls visual valued the
accessibility event go ahead and add
accessibility handlers to your view and
then click here when you're done